Doctor Who casting news is in again so I
just got home from a really long weekend
and I really just wanted to go to bed
but um this news broke so I got to stay
up and shoot this and edit this and get
this out while still relevant so we have
got casting news for supporting
characters for Doctor Who for when Jodie
Whittaker starts her tenure as the
doctor and Chris Chibnall starts his
tenure as the showrunner normally I try
and memorize these but like I said I am
tired I am just gonna read these so
there are actually this four apparently
but the the big news is Bradley Walsh is
gonna be playing the character of Graham
largely rumored to be the new companion
that's I mean that is news is the first
time has been confirmed I know his name
was getting tossed about before
Bradley ball says Walsh is an actor who
I don't really know next up we have toss
in Cole playing a character called Ryan
tossing Cole was apparently in the force
awakens I didn't notice him so he's also
an actor I don't know and finally manda
Gil is playing Yasmine
I don't know this actress either and
additionally Sharon D Clarke who I also
don't know is joining the series as an
unspecified returning role so she's
probably almost definitely some sort of
earthbound character that they run into
in a couple of different stories but I
think the big thing to focus on is gonna
be Bradley Walsh because I doubt we're
getting into a multi companion traveling
with a doctor scenario it's possible in
terms of these these other castings but
I doubt they're gonna leap right into
that right off the bat because I mean we
need a chance to get to know this new
doctor and the quick way to make that
difficult to do is gonna be to overcrowd
the TARDIS and I think they know well
enough not to do that so in terms of
Bradley Walsh as I said I don't know the
guy's an actor so he's very diff
for me to judge but that said even if I
did know them but as an actor that's not
really an indication of what this
character is going to be like so I can
only really speak in the broad strokes
which is older male companion okay I
mean the thing is I should be more
excited about this than I am because
it's the sort of thing I've been asking
for for a long time I've been saying for
years now I am sick to death of under 30
female from modern earth I'm really
really done with it and this is
definitely not that that said I don't
know the timing seems a little odd that
we have a male companion at the same
time as we have a female doctor it I
mean ultimately whether or not it works
is all gonna come down to the dynamic
the chemistry and the writing so I
before I make any possible complaints or
some positions about that let me say
that up front if this is what written
works great I mean that's what it needs
to be regardless but I can't help but
get the slight twinge that they made a
male companion out of fear that like
people were going to go ah there's no
male presence and I'm I know there are
some people who would have said that I
don't know if that would have been such
a strong reaction that they would have
needed to do this but I don't know it
just feels like a slightly reflexive
move and that you know that said the
only thing that I would worry about at
all is if he has any sort of romantic
entanglement with the doctor now I think
I was really really grateful that there
was no romantic angle for Peter Capaldi
even though they went there with Clara
and Smith I don't know why but I'm glad
that that was all gone during his or I'm
hoping that will continue to be the case
because that was another thing I was
done with and thankfully I haven't had
to have for the past three series now so
I really hope that that doesn't happen
I suspect the
there again I think because of how aware
they are of what some of the major
concerns about the doctor being woman
that they won't have her attracted to
him that probably won't happen just
because that that would be an absolute
minefield even if there was a good story
reason to do it however that doesn't
necessarily mean that they aren't gonna
have him attracted to her and I'm not
sure I care about that either
unfortunately it's and then this is not
necessarily the show's fault it is just
kind of the expectation because of how
these shows always work out that you put
a guy in a girl of comparable age and I
think he is older than her but you know
of what are conceived as compatible ages
and even if people aren't actively
calling for them to be put together it
almost seems inevitable so I think it's
gonna be difficult to avoid having that
vibe seep in on the thing again with the
right chemistry between them and the
right writing there are still ways to
just have it be very clear that that's
not ever going to happen just by you
know tweaking the the way everything
functions correctly but yeah the broad
strokes is this is the kind of change to
a campaign that I really wanted although
the timing I don't love because we've
already got enough other major changes
that it seems like an odd time to also
do that big companion changes well
although I mean I suppose if you're
changing everything else anyways why not
yeah I don't know and that's kind of
where I am with a lot of the the Doctor
Who stuff until we get something more
concrete and like I said I think the
main thing I'm watching for right now is
to see a costume on Jodie Whittaker you
know an official one because you know
the hoodie that that was a placeholder
that was a look that it wasn't a bad
look if that's what they actually go
with I have thoughts I'll give on that
but until they lock down and present her
in her costume I really don't think
there's enough to go on and I feel it's
much the same way with with Bradley
Washington till we see an image of how
he actually appears in the show or maybe
if they
you know give us one of those little
sort of clips previewing what the
dynamic between them is which they've
done before you know they did with Bill
and Capaldi um although when they did
that it didn't work for me even though I
ended up really liking Bill later I'm
setting that aside until we get stuff
like that we there isn't a lot to judge
it's just it's just names and okay
you know it's I it's the sort of stuff
that I feel like I have to talk about
there's there's it's too big an
announcement for me to ignore but at the
same time I don't really have heavy
thoughts I'm just like okay it's another
person that's involved in this it's not
a FERPA to actually form an opinion on I
get in bed partly because I don't know
this actor maybe if I did I'd have more
to say but yeah I think I think I'm sort
of run circles around that point for
long enough we could leave it at that so
the casting announcements I and I didn't
really talk about the other ones and
again I don't know anything about them I
know even less about how they're gonna
function the show so it's really really
really hard to say much of anything I
depressingly I have no doubt that there
are some people who are going to make a
big deal out of the fact that of these
additional people cast there is a
there's two people of color and please
don't Eve even if if that upsets you or
you think that's more evidence of a bias
that you are convinced the show or the
BBC has just don't in the comments if we
could set that aside but aside from that
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available in
iTunes and stitcher I'm also one half of
the punch like a girl podcast also
available on iTunes and stitcher through
the fire and water network fire and
water podcast.com so until next time
hopefully I'll have gotten more sleep
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]